[Música]
sale 138 américa de france 24 está
conmigo en el estudio más romeros a la
mara bienvenida buena mañana de
miércoles hoy vamos a hablar de la
investigación científica y también de
dinero como mezclamos esto buenos días
raúl o pues sí precisamente vamos a
hablar de esta relación entre los dos
que a veces puede ser un poco tramposa
como vamos a ver ahora de qué estamos
hablando por ejemplo de esos alimentos
súper alimentos o incluso ha pasado con
el alcohol con el tabaco hace años que
la industria ha financiado estudios ahí
hablamos del dinero para decir que estos
alimentos o que estas sustancias son
saludables entonces bueno para analizar
todo esto estamos con el doctor oscar
franco que es profesor de salud pública
de la universidad de berna como cada
miércoles doctor muy buenos días hay
muchos de estos estudios que afirman
haber encontrado el dorado en términos
de nutrición en términos de salud qué
riesgos tiene eso cuando estos estudios
están financiados por la misma industria
de esos alimentos
si yo no solamente es el dorado y es
casi cada semana que escuchamos acerca
de ese superalimento que va a prevenir
el cáncer en los problemas del
colesterol problemas del corazón
etcétera la verdad lo que esto crea es
varios riesgos en primer lugar puede
generar costumbres que se perpetúan
creencias de que médica que un
tratamiento con un alimento puede ser
beneficioso para algo pero que no lo es
que no estaba sola evidencia segundo
puede confundir a la gente porque como
cada día y cada semana tenemos un
alimento una dieta diferente que se pone
de moda entonces la gente se puede
confundir tercero también hace que los
investigadores pues no puedan enfocarse
quizás o dedicarse a la investigación en
alimentos que son más importantes y eso
hace un desbalance en términos de lo que
se publica puede que se publique más los
estudios que prueban que los alimentos
tienen un efecto y no los que prueban
que no lo tienen entonces eso crea un
desbalance en la evidencia que existe
para las recomendaciones a la población
doctor los saludo muy buena tarde le
quiero preguntar por los ejemplos
históricos que tenemos de estudios
financiados por él con una industria de
productos que ahora sabemos que no son
nada saludables
si el ejemplo yo creo que más importante
está el tabaco los productos del tabaco
el cigarrillo que durante décadas se
consideraron que eran buenos para la
salud e incluso había médicos que
prescribían 1 o 2 cigarrillos cada 8
horas para prevenir las enfermedades del
corazón ya a mediados del siglo 20
aparece la evidencia y luego empieza
toda la fuerte batalla entre
investigadores y también industria para
poder determinar si los cigarrillos
realmente tenían un riesgo o no con el
alcohol también tenemos una situación
similar aún seguimos todavía
preguntándonos si el alcohol es bueno si
no el pueblo y en qué condiciones y qué
características y lo que vemos en
general en la evidencia es que cualquier
cantidad de alcohol si lo miramos ya a
nivel general y no solamente mirando el
corazón no el cáncer o alguna tejido en
particular cualquier cantidad de alcohol
puede ser perjudicial para la salud y
eso lo hemos visto cómo está esta
industria ha financiado muchas veces la
investigación y también a los médicos o
al personal de salud directamente doctor
frank o lo que sucede a veces también es
que al final esa industria pues si la
investigación requiere muchísimo dinero
estamos hablando de mí de dólares y si
la industria es la única que lo puede
financiar qué alternativas tienen los
investigadores centros de investigación
médicos para hacer que esto sea más
transparente
y es verdad porque cada estudio de estos
puede costar por pequeño entre unos 500
mil dólares o cerca de un millón de
dólares y también lo que hace es que se
genere una gran cantidad de estudios
pequeños con evidencia muy limitada y no
estudios más grandes que requerirían
millones y millones de dólares pero por
lo financiero
yo creo que es importante aquí tener más
subvención por parte del estado de otras
instituciones que sean más transparentes
y también hacer que la investigación que
la financiación que los investigadores
que nosotros mismos como científicos
seamos más transparentes en declara los
intereses el dinero que se ha recibido
en qué forma se ha recibido y también
tener en cuenta que muchas veces los
medios pues no toman en cuenta quién
financia o quien no financia la
investigación cuando se presentan en la
comunicación eso se puede mirar en el
artículo en el artículo de investigación
se mira quién pagó por el estudio y eso
debería ser declarado directamente
cuando se presenta la noticia y cuando
se presenta se presenta el hallazgo de
la manera más transparente posible más
allá de eso tenemos que tomar
restricciones mucho más amplias mucho
más transparentes y también contratos
que sean transparentes y abiertos al
público entre investigadores e industria
para que se pueda consultar el origen de
la investigación y que reglas se
implementaron para poder encontrar los
hallazgos cáceres que se están
publicando doctor además este campo de
la nutrición como venimos hablando del
pse es una investigación puede darse
también en los medicamentos
por supuesto de hecho de mi primera
investigación cuando empecé era
investigación miré un estudio de costo
efectividad de las estatinas que es un
medicamento para bajar el colesterol y
era a principios del 2000 2003 2004
cuando no habían salido de patente y era
muy costosas y encontramos una gran
variabilidad en la costo efectiva de las
estatinas que se explicaba
principalmente por quién financiaba a
los estudios que era financiado por la
industria pues tendrían a ser más
beneficiosos en términos de decir que
eran baratos y se podían comprar pues
era financiado por gobierno por
universidades
quizás exageraban y decían que eran
demasiado costosos no se sabía en qué
parte estaba la verdad entonces no es un
problema solamente con los alimentos
sino también con los medicamentos doctor
entonces para terminar ya estaba
hablando de revisar bien quién financia
los estudios que otros tips que otras
cosas podemos decirle al público general
para que puedan saber si los estudios
son fiables o no
sin poner siempre todo dentro del marco
de lo que ya se conoce mirar muy bien la
fuente de dónde está saliendo la
información si son medios que se pueden
creer y leer siempre más allá del tema
buscar en internet hablar también con el
médico si es el caso de pacientes hablar
con su médico con su nutricionista y
pedirles que les ayuden para poder
entender qué beneficios podría tener
para ellos mismos o si no fuese
solamente una moda
pues muchas gracias doctor por todas
estas recomendaciones nos vemos la
semana próxima así es doctor muchísimas
gracias mar también gracias por este
nuevo espacio de salud nos vemos mañana
usted y yo para seguir hablando por
supuesto de salud pasamos a saludar a
nuestro segundo mitad del día
[Música]